katia bonjour alors expliquez nous
quelle est cette affaire en quoi elle
est si importante
et bien c'est une affaire qui est
difficilement croyable est ce que vous
nous disiez c'est vrai c'est le secret
des sources des journalistes qui se joue
encore une fois aujourd'hui alors dans
cette affaire il ya trois personnes
le journaliste edward perrin et puis
raphaël aller antoine deltour deux
anciens salariés d'un cabinet
luxembourgeois price moteur cooper à
vous donc pour faire simple pwc raphaël
aller et antoine deltour avec constater
que le cabinet recouvrer une histoire de
fraude fiscale et donc ils ont donné
leurs informations et leurs documents au
journaliste edward perrin est en fait
ces documents ont servi à une révélation
incroyable en selle de loxley qs en 2014
c'est-à-dire la mise à jour d'un système
d'évasion fiscale orchestrée depuis le
luxembourg et les journalistes
enquêteurs ont découvert 340 accord pour
des multinationales afin de leur
permettre d'échapper à l'impôt alors
finalement c'était une bonne nouvelle
pour le fisc français car ça pouvait lui
permettre de récupérer des millions oui
l'état français n'aurait-il pas dû
féliciter ceux qui ont permis cette
découverte d'évasion fiscale pardon eh
bien oui en théorie comme ça peut être
le cas parfois aux états unis mais n'ont
pas du tout la justice de deux pays la
france et le luxembourg s'est retourné
contre ce qu'on peut considérer comme
des lanceurs d'alert pourquoi et bien
parce que leurs documents comme la
plupart des documents d'une entreprise
sont considérés confidentiel c'est
logique donc il y avait un dilemme soit
antoine deltour et raphaël allez ne
dévoilait pas les document ne vous est
pas cette révélation qu'il n'y a pas de
lutte contre la fraude fiscale soit ils
les dérober en quelque sorte et donc se
mettaient en infraction et donc pwc a
profité de cette législation très
avantageuse pour les entreprises le
secret des entreprises ils ont obtenu en
2014 quelque chose d'incroyable une
ordonnance par un juge de metz de saisie
de la correspondance avec édouard perrin
et des documents chez raphaël allait à
son domicile
alors en fait là on touche à quelque
chose de très grave c'est à dire le
secret des sources dans notre métier
c'est à dire que nous deux
assurer la confidentialité à ceux qui
nous font des révélations non seulement
pwc à retrouver la source
raphaël aller et ensuite il a traduit en
justice alors katia quels ont été les
suites judiciaires pour les trois hommes
alors elles sont quand même lourd d'un
ils ont été attaqués au luxembourg par
pwc le journaliste edward perrin a été
relaxé mais antoine deltour et raphaël
aller ont été condamnés à une amende et
de la prison il ya eu un appel en 2018
antoine deltour a été considérée lanceur
d'alert pas trop tôt finalement mais
pour raphaël aller c'est une autre
histoire
la cour a décidé que les documents qu'il
avait fournies n'était pas une
révélation mais de simples documents
confidentiels et donc c'est considéré
comme du vol fraude informatique et
blanchiment donc il ya un autre procès
aujourd'hui en france celui dont on
parle qui à l'initiative du journaliste
edward perrin ils demandent l'annulation
de la saisie des documents et de la
correspondance au domicile de raffaele
aller à la demande de pwc et la surprise
en 2018 il a été débouté et lors de ce
procès en appel est bien la tendance est
similaire c'est à dire que la justice va
peut-être donner tort à edward p 1
alors la question est ce qu'on
privilégie le droit des affaires et donc
in fine et le droit de tricher la
liberté il a nécessité d'informer bien
la sentence est rendu à 9 heures merci
beaucoup katia donc on va suivre cela
bien évidemment avec vous katia
technique donc
retour sur cette affaire de secret des
sources des journalistes